all right captain time for an evaluation
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so new trailer for Captain
Marvel and before I talk about this one
I kind of want to address something kind
of left over from the last trailer
um because I did what I usually do which
was watch the trailer give my thoughts
rather than like get a gauge on what
everyone else thought of the trailer
first I completely missed that it became
a big thing that everyone was like brie
Larson so wooden and if I'd realized
that that was gonna be something that
people made a thing out of at the time I
would have brought this up before but
I'll just touch on it now you guys do
realize that for that teaser especially
we're probably only seeing like the
first half out of stuff from the first
half hour of that movie and it's really
clearly implied that she's been
brainwashed right like you didn't you
did get that right plus like if she's
been brainwashed not just in general but
to be a soldier yeah she kind of would
be wooden that would be their ideal they
don't want her having a ton of
personality in her own opinion again
that's sort of me like extrapolating but
like it just struck me as a really weird
criticism given what that teaser implied
was going on and I I think Marvel might
actually agree with me because they seem
to have gone out of their way to pick
out more clips where she exudes a little
bit more personality not a ton of it
again I really suspect that we're only
seeing clips from I'd say it most the
first half of this movie except for
maybe a couple of like it's certain
special effects shot or whatnot speak in
the special effects I do like the
effects in this I think they're really
cool I love the look of Captain Marvel's
powers I love the glow and sort of the
fire eNOS but it's not like quite fire
that they've got going on around her I
think it looks cool I like it it's
really weird for me to see to see Nick
Fury with hair I don't know I've just
got
so used to Sam Jackson ball eyepatch and
now to eyes in the hair I'm like I mean
I know it's you but okay I gotta
reconfigure my brain and again I think
we're getting more stuff laid out that
we can probably start to put together
what the likely story going on here is
so if you're worried about speculation
which I usually don't do too much of but
I feel like there's been enough
breadcrumbs laid in this new trailer
that I would feel weird not doing a
little bit of speculation so I'm gonna
go ahead and do that so you know it lays
out right the front so there's scrubs
and they're the bad guys and I'm like
yeah that is absolutely not the whole
story which honestly if you're not new
to the MCU you kind of already know
because Captain Marvel is a rig is
initially at the start of the story
serving the Kree who are the Kree oh the
blue guys that you know Ronan the
villain from Gallic gardens of the
galaxy vol 1 or if you watch agents of
shield and learned even more about the
Creed not particularly nice folks so I
think what will be interesting is
whether or not we're in a situation
where the Skrulls are actually not even
that much of a threat and in fact the
reason they're on earth is because
they're hiding and they're trying to
avoid being in a war anymore or if it's
just gonna be a case of no the scrolls
aren't good but the guys who Captain
Marvel is serving aren't good either so
like we're in we're now stuck in the
middle of these two warring factions
which is not a place we should be I
could see it going either way and I
could see you know getting decent
dividends you know story-wise out of
either approach um oh and let me just
say this now in case I forget it that
cat's a Skrull like we all know that
right then the canopy and it's like
there's no way it's not I mean let's
just get that on the record other than
that it just kind of reinforces a lot of
what was in the first trailer the the
eye and it touches on a lot of the same
ideas of you know her past is something
she can barely remember being on earth
is starting to bring it back so I think
the question for me is how gradual
that's gonna be my suspicion is not
especially gradual at least in terms of
her flip
on the Cree I figured since you know we
all know that that's gonna happen event
you know before the end of the movie
anyway they'll probably flip that switch
fairly early on um but maybe not mean
that she suddenly remembers everything
about herself like she'll still have
things to sort of realize about herself
and get a more sense about her place in
the universe now that you know it's not
what she thought it was that will
probably get drawn out but I think her
leaving the service of the creed that
probably happens by the end of act 1
that's probably front end stuff and then
from there how it pans out just depends
on what they built up as being the the
major things going on from there I'm
still kind of thrown off by the by the
the helmet Mohawk look like it's not a
bad look I think I don't love it in the
comics either and it's actually really
hard for me to nail down why cuz I like
Mohawks especially on women weirdly I
don't know why like I love storms mohawk
look again I don't know why I just do
but something about this one I don't
know this it's never worked for me again
even in comics I don't really love that
look
so I mean it's just something about it
doesn't click for me but that's it
that's a design issue the effect you
know of it being there and like kind of
coming off and the hair drops down I put
a nice in effect as far as that goes I'm
not sure I've got too much else to say
about it it was kind of cool seeing a
little bit more of the of the old lady
reaction and see her I actually started
ninja flipping about I'm like okay
that's just fun like if you're gonna
have the scrolls there that's the kind
of stuff that I want to see at least in
one scene this sort of the fun and the
joy of oh it's an old lady oh my god she
hit an old lady oh my god the old lady
hit back and is doing ninja flips like
that's that's the kind of fun we should
be having if we're gonna be doing the
scrolls so like I I like that I doubt
that that's gonna be the approach for
the scrolls for the whole movie but I
like that they that it looks like
they're gonna be taking advantage of
those kinds of moments so like that's
cool um I'm not sure I've got too much
else to think about it like this trailer
didn't blow me away by any means but it
kind of reinforced what I
what was working for me in the previous
trailer so I'm looking at this I'm you
know I'm seeing effects that look decent
I'm seeing actors I like I'm seeing like
little moments that are kind of cool and
fun brie Larson while I'm again I'm not
blown away I'm like yeah I can't wait to
see her like I put off by her at all so
I'm like cool let's let's see what
you've got like I'm in a I think my best
position on this film is that I am
accepting I'm ready for this film
I'm not pumped for it unnecessarily I'm
not like ya can't wait but I am kind of
like I want to see what you got let's
see so you know I I don't know I unless
like there's may something major shifts
in terms of what gets shown I doubt I'll
do reviews on any more trailers they put
out cuz usually by now the the way the
trailer cycle tends to go is you get
your teaser and then you get your full
trade you know and your teaser is just
here's a look at the characters here's a
general feel and the vibe of the thing
here's your basic premise maybe and then
your first full trailer actually lays
out some of the plot a bit and then
usually any subsequent quiet truck
Wailers what trailers that come out
after that are are just adding more
detail and more information to what was
kind of already shown in the first two
it's very rare that a later trailer like
really throws a curveball at you and
usually if they do I end up wishing that
I hadn't forget seen it in a trailer so
I mean if I have any restraint I
actually won't be looking at any more
trailers for this film but even if I do
I doubt I'm gonna talk about it again
until the film actually comes out
because I do plan to see it so latest
Captain Marvel trailer what do you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it whole bunch of stuff you can do
because it's buttons and links including
one to my patreon if you are feeling
that kind of generous and there's a
whole bunch of links besides that if you
don't want to go to that one and you
know what you don't want to click on
them that's fine too because at the end
of the day folks you're the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]